morality tends to get lost very quickly
when you start working at the scp
foundation during the whirlwind of basic
training site orientation and learning
the difference between euclid ketter and
thomial object classes you'll have to
make peace with the fact that as a new
member of foundation staff you'll
probably end up having to turn a blind
eye to doing some morally compromising
things then again it's such a normal
everyday occurrence at the foundation
that almost everyone working for them is
desensitized to whatever ethically
dubious or downright violent tasks they
have to partake in and at the end of the
day everyone knows that it's all for the
greater good to keep anomalies securely
in containment for the benefit and
protection of humanity but the one part
of foundation life that simon bennett
just couldn't reason with was the very
existence of d-class personnel now
anyone with previous knowledge of the
scp foundation's dubious practices will
of course be aware of d-class but to
simon who had just been recruited as a
member of site security personnel the
whole concept was not only alien but
completely abhorrent d-class personnel
as he'd come to learn were completely
expendable their ranks were filled with
convicted felons almost all of them
guilty of violent crimes the foundation
seemed to have a habit of plucking
inmates from the highest security
prisons and penitentiaries in the world
covering their tracks by staging the
deaths of these unwilling recruits into
d-class from there these criminals were
essentially used as little more than
human lab rats and it was this part that
really didn't sit well with simon the
very idea left him torn on the one hand
d-class were arguably the worst of the
worst most if not all of them were
guilty of horrific and brutal crimes
some that could never be forgiven by
anyone but on the other simon struggled
to rationalize taking these prisoners
from their incarceration only to subject
them to anomalous creatures and entities
most scps could do things to a d-class
that were almost as bad as what these
convicts had done to their victims and
some could dole out far far worse fates
did their actions make their cruel
faiths justifiable did d-class personnel
deserve the amount of punishment for
their crimes simon didn't know it was a
perplexing moral conundrum most days at
the foundation those questions echoed
around his head he was probably better
suited to a role in the ethics committee
than rank and file security he was
uncertain if it was better to leave a
violent murderer to serve their sentence
in prison until their eventual execution
or abduct them and use them as a d-class
guinea pig it wasn't long before his
fellow security officers tried to
dissuade simon from questioning the
foundation's methods reminding him how
lucky he was to be selected to join them
and how an easy application of amnestics
could take that all away leaving him not
only jobless but his memory wiped as
well ultimately as weeks turned into
months then became years in the blink of
an eye security officer bennett's moral
compass was ground down he started
getting used to the idea of the
foundation's way of doing things asking
fewer and fewer questions to oppose how
morally and ethically ambiguous a lot of
their experiments and procedures were
obedience to others slowly became apathy
and the simon that had once been
concerned with the ethics of d-class
experimentation soon began looking at
them as expendable assets just like the
rest of the scp foundation did he even
started to resent a few of them that
seemed to have gotten off easy on a few
occasions a member of d-class personnel
got to interact with the friendly kind
of anomaly it didn't seem fair simon
thought that while he and the other
security personnel had to put their
lives on the line whenever a dangerous
scp breached containment meanwhile a
d-class who might have been a multiple
murderer or domestic terrorist got to
sit in a testing chamber with a friendly
entity like
scp-999 the tickle monster keeping up to
date with the special containment
procedures for the various anomalous
objects and beings held at the
foundation was an essential part of a
security officer's job ongoing testing
and new discoveries that were about an
entity often led to them needing new
updated measures to keep them securely
contained but it was during a routine
check of these procedures that simon
came across something strange well maybe
not so strange when you work at the scp
foundation but definitely a noticeable
level of strangeness reading through the
containment procedures for one of the
anomalies housed at the site simon found
a list of instructions fairly standard
stuff for the foundation the strange
part was that he was sure that he had
never read this list before but at the
same time it wasn't a new update
recently added to an entry in the scp
archive it was paradoxically brand new
information a detailed description of
containment measures yet also seemingly
something that had been written and
archived ages ago reading through the
instructions they described a process
that was essential to keeping one of the
site's anomalies secure it had even been
given its own name the special
containment procedures referring to the
whole practice as a monthly termination
the more that simon read his eyes would
widen further as he learned exactly what
the steps of this process entailed in
his earlier days he wouldn't have
thought of this so-called monthly
termination as excessive a needlessly
cruel act even by the standards of the
scp foundation but that was the old
simon a man who hadn't yet become jaded
by his work before he had come to adopt
the same apathy and disregard for life
as his fellow foundation personnel
reaching the end of the passage
describing monthly termination simon
alerted the other security officers
making sure they read the procedure too
some unknown feelings stirred deep
within simon telling him this needed to
be carried out and it had to happen
right now
before long members of staff had been
told to read the entry on monthly
termination each one passing it on to
their colleagues then simon and a large
detachment of other guards began
marching towards the cell blocks where
d-class personnel were imprisoned almost
a third of the site's incarcerated
inmates were rounded up it couldn't have
been any more than a few hundred simon
wasn't sure he couldn't see all of them
from where he was standing but mostly he
didn't care all he could focus on was
following the monthly termination
procedure to the letter together he and
the security detachment escorted the
collected d-class personnel through the
facility single file all marching in
efficient and perfectly synchronized
motion it was almost like a
choreographed military display if he
hadn't been so preoccupied with thinking
only of the procedure simon might have
realized how strange all this was all
the personnel were moving at once in
such flawless timing even though this
hadn't been planned in advance and yet
he and the other personnel had only just
learned about monthly termination and
yet they were carrying it out as if they
had done it a thousand times before the
security officers continued ferrying the
d-classes through the facility
eventually leading the convicted felons
to the main entrance the doors were
opened without question nobody who had
read the monthly termination instruction
saw what was going on as anything out of
the ordinary a long winding row of
inmates and foundation issue orange
jumpsuits were then guided out of the
site's main doors instructed by the
security to keep walking even further
none of them knew how far they'd really
walked a lot of d-class personnel
complained and moaned but the few that
tried to leave the single file line were
quickly put back in place by the
security department most of them were
directly verbally aggressive cursing and
threatening the security officers but
they seemed compliant walking the way
they were told to it was as if they had
to obey almost like their legs wouldn't
let them resist one begged to be let go
turning to simon and pleading not to be
taken wherever it was they were going
i'm sorry simon replied plainly with
barely any emotion behind his words it
was a lie he didn't feel sorry in fact
he hadn't even been sure why he
apologized at all the reply had happened
almost unnaturally like something else
was speaking through him he wasn't even
sure how far away they'd gotten from the
facility it might have felt like miles
if he hadn't been thinking about it but
he wasn't none of the officers were they
were following their instructions
totally unaware that they'd been walking
for so long that they were starting to
get blisters they all somehow knew they
had gotten far enough beyond the reach
and sight of the foundation facility
they started in so far in fact that the
surveillance systems wouldn't be able to
see them still moving with the same
complete synchronous timing simon and
the other security officers herded the
d-class personnel towards a wooded
clearing they formed a ring around the
inmates before pushing them down onto
their knees a few of them hung their
heads some even shedding a tear they had
already figured out what was about to
happen those that hadn't quickly caught
up when they saw the security officers
covering or deactivating their head
cameras then reaching for their sidearms
when they returned to the facility simon
and the other officers would all give
the same story they collectively led a
third of the science d-class to an area
out of surveillance range and executed
them all with their handguns at least
that's how they all remembered the
incident but what they thought they'd
done didn't quite match what had
actually happened naturally the
foundation higher-ups quickly got wind
of what happened and of such a massive
expenditure of their expendable d-class
resources the incident forced the scp
foundation to launch a full-blown
investigation into the actions of simon
the other security officers and
additional personnel on site they
quickly recognized the pattern of
behavior they had seen it before they
already knew not one of the guards had
actually fired their weapons in fact
none of them had been acting of their
own free will simon and the others had
no idea that the monthly termination
procedure didn't exist in the
foundation's records and was actually
the symptom of an
scp-2193 event all those d-class that
had been rounded up and marched out into
the middle of nowhere were still gone
though not shot point-blank like the
officers thought but the prisoners were
still no longer alive either although
he'd never remember it when simon had
been stood amongst his fellow officers
one of the d-class had begun floating
upwards lifted off the ground by some
invisible force the convicted felon
drifted about three meters in the air
without warning the prisoner was then
launched up practically fired towards
the sky like a rocket traveling into the
upper atmosphere at several times the
speed of sound one by one the members of
d-class all began experiencing the same
thing floating off the ground only to be
catapulted up into the stratosphere with
such speed and force that they vanish
from view in seconds meanwhile all simon
and the other security officers did was
stand by and watch keeping their head
cams covered or switched off the last of
the d-class prisoners stood in the
clearing the one that had asked simon to
be set free he was still asking begging
to be helped down as his feet were
hoisted up against his will practically
screaming for someone anyone to do
something his eyes locked with simon's
for a split second before he too was
sent hurtling into the sky moving that
high in that fast isn't something a
human being is at all likely to survive
now rid of the d-class that they had led
to their deaths all the gathered
security personnel looked up it was
night starlight cast across an inky
canvas of dark sky but simon was fixated
on the moon they all were none of them
could take their eyes off it as it
slowly appeared to blink like a watchful
eye hanging in the space above them not
one of them would remember what they had
seen or what they had truly done no
member of d-class was a saint it's true
they were murderers criminals and
dangerous individuals maybe some of them
were so bad that they did deserve to be
used as test subjects to die at the
hands of anomalous entities but then
again does anyone really deserve to go
out like that little is known about the
point of origin of scp-2193
while it affects the documents stored
within the foundation's database it does
not function like a computer virus or
artificial intelligence instead
scp-2193-1 is an anomalous piece of
information or an info hazard as scps
like this are known it has been known to
infect digital files specifically the
special containment procedures for
various entities objects and creatures
that the foundation has recorded in its
archives even their most talented
computer engineers and anomalous
researchers cannot determine how this
infohazard is able to accomplish this it
seems to infect files at random without
any repeating pattern in its timing or
the type of scp files it appears in upon
infection a file now containing
scp-2193-1 will include references to a
monthly termination of d-class personnel
making it as an essential process for
keeping an anomaly secure anyone that
reads this suffers from what is known as
a memetic effect essentially they will
believe what they have read and believe
that they have always been aware of this
information on top of that a person
infected by a cp 2193-1 will accept it
as true that the monthly termination is
a legitimate and accepted practice
within the scp foundation they can't be
convinced that killing hundreds of
d-class personnel is anything less than
justified now you might be forgiven for
thinking that uninfected personnel can
easily explain to those who have been
affected by a cp 2193-1
that the monthly termination isn't an
official foundation policy but this
infohazard has proven itself to be
particularly infectious when spreading
its memetic influence any member of
foundation personnel not yet exposed to
scp-2193-1 can be easily convinced that
the monthly termination is both morally
acceptable and a foundation-held
procedure that is absolutely necessary
for anomaly containment if anyone that
has read and therefore believes the
monthly termination process then they
will display a lack of cognitive
dissonance whenever someone attempts to
present them with information that
conflicts with
scp-2193-1 while no document within
their internal database has a record of
the monthly termination procedure back
in january of 1999 the foundation was
able to witness the process second hand
via one of its agents during an scp-2193
event agent usan's head camera was left
uncovered recording excerpts of the
precise and perfectly choreographed
execution of numerous d-class personnel
much like the event simon was a part of
an unknown anomaly caused the earth's
moon to appear to blink it is believed
by some within the foundation that this
is the result of a form of eldritch
entity a being that demands a
substantial human sacrifice every month
this being as of yet remains
unidentified just as unclear is this
anomaly's intentions motives or how it
is able to affect or perhaps use the
moon of course the scp foundation has
its own personnel stationed up there
however during recorded instances of
scp-2193 events their agents at luna
area 32 have reported no unusual
activity or abnormalities at the
corresponding times the running theory
among some personnel is that the moon
isn't this unidentified being's actual
eye but some kind of ocular device like
a spy glass that allows it to observe
the monthly termination whatever this
being is it apparently possesses an
immense level of power how exactly it is
able to create scp-2193-1
and infiltrate the foundation's internal
database with that infohazard is still
unknown as is the exact reason why it
goes to such trouble such incalculable
lengths seemingly just for the purpose
of killing so many d-class inmates the
immediate assumption albeit admittedly a
morbid and cynical one held by most
foundation researchers studying scp-2193
is that this entity needs this almost
ritualistic monthly sacrifice in order
to sustain itself one idea suggests it
could be a creature that opposes how the
foundation uses its d-class personnel
maybe it just like simon used to
questions the morality of convicts being
used as expendable guinea pigs and as
such it uses its eldritch levels of
power to remove them from the
foundation's reach for good or perhaps
despite its subterfuge this being feeds
on those who have wronged others making
d-class personnel prime candidates that
would certainly explain why the monthly
termination procedure causes security
officers to only bring the foundation's
force of expendable convicts and after
all there are benevolent scps out there
even friendly ones so it stands to
reason that this being could be trying
to rid the world of people who are bad
enough to be put into d-class but then
again this world is rarely so kind
scp-2193-1 makes foundation officers
bring d-classes out to where they can't
be seen causing them to cover their head
cameras and believe a phony story about
execution by sidearm so nobody knows
what really happens to them it even
hides the info hazard detailing the
monthly termination procedures at random
moving it around to a new file whenever
it's detected such great effort is taken
by this entity to cover its tracks which
would suggest a far more nefarious goal
it is entirely possible that this being
does all this simply to amuse itself
expending countless lives and foundation
resources purely for a sick sadistic
form of entertainment with no way of
knowing the entity's true intention the
scp foundation can only sit and
vigilantly wait an artificial
intelligence surveying their database
for the next instance of scp-2193
now go check out scp-055 anti-meme
unknown and scp-1025 encyclopedia of
common diseases for more insights into
infohazards scare inducing secrets and
truths too terrifying to tell but only
if you're brave enough